alors avec qu'ils partiront exactement
alors sur mon moteur de recherche génie
animateur télé qui aime jouer au poker
aime jouer au tennis et en même temps
qui me laisse du temps pour pouvoir lire
j'ai trouvé cyril hanouna
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien partir avec nikos ne pas
visiter les cyclades corps bien partir
avec des gens qu'ils n'avaient yvon et
puis avec qui vous ne partiriez
absolument pas vouloir avec gilles
verdez avec qui vous partez en vacances
bah moi j'avais dit nikos aussi aux non
mais j'ai honte d'être français avec
elsa parce qu'elle est bon est trop
mignonne je suis tendu je suis ni cause
si vous acceptez les deux je pars quand
même ce moment par ensemble soit sinon
je change
je me permets une petite infidélité et
je prends laurent delahousse à l'euro de
l'offensive est de coutume donne des
idées
excellent choix et je ne portais pas
avec je crois que je pars pas avec
patrick sébastien
alors avec qui je partirai exactement
alors sur mon moteur de recherche génie
animateur télé qui aime jouer au poker
aime jouer au tennis et en même temps
qui me laisse du temps pour pouvoir lire
j'ai trouvé cyril hanouna
alors vous vous avez vraiment envie d'
une meilleure et on se remet à rêver de
la chaîne mais voudront pas et cela
s'est autodissous oui vous êtes combien
15,3 à pas mal et vous ne partez pas vu
qui avec amiens
pourquoi est ce qu'en fait il est trop
kazan il m'a dit qu'ils détestent et
partir ils aiment rester chez lui il
déteste les avions il déteste faire ses
valises
salon goisses haut et moi j'adore partir
donc je pense qu'on voit là je pourrai
pas être compatible avec annie pour ces
vacances là avec une part en vacances
avec jean pierre foucault a cédé sacrée
soirée avec lui surtout il a plongé vers
l'année dans la piscine de d'intervilles
parce que il a surfé sur cette activité
pendant tout l'été quand j'étais gosse
et surtout je crois qu'il vit dans les
alentours de marseille hilary ware
carrick voitures de collection en
décapotable 4l et une petite promenade
un petit tour
c'est du grand n'importe quoi qu'est ce
que vous avez fait ce que vous croyez
jean pierre foucault envie de partir
mais dans ce cas nul il annule tout de
suite gerbi et avec qui vous ne voulez
pas parti avec georges pernoud ce bon
vieux loup de mer parce que j'ai levé le
regarder je pensais à la photo que j'ai
préparé moi je pars avec vous à mon
passé grand chose et quelques failles
non mais bastien d'abord pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que vous êtes très
sympathique et c'est vrai vous êtes
assez drôle je suis en train de de
promouvoir mon nouveau spectacle qui
démarre à paris vers 7 heures un
spectacle assez drôle rappelle rappelle
que j'ai peint des premières bourses des
vrais voilà et puis et puis j'ai vu
votre femme ayant même très très bas
c'est drôle aussi
voilà donc et puis surtout c'est aussi
j'ai si je veux faire un barbecue
d'accord ok donc vous venez pour qu'on
fasse un barbecue pendant vous fait ma
faim pour moi c'est franchement ici à 11
il est chaude
stéphane plaza a ouai c'est le meilleur
je le trouve sympa gentil les droits
humains généreux j'adore c'est pas le
concours du meilleur animateur ce avec
qui on a envie de partir on va là pour
être avec tige parfois ça avec arthur
partage rien nous n'avons pas les mêmes
valeurs vous avez alors il vous fera
découvrir pas mal de choses arthur alors
avec qui je partirai comme animateur et
ben justement j'y avais pas pensé mais
calmes et parce qu'on se rapproche un
peu il est très casanier moi aussi je
suis très casanière et sinon changement
de génération tirer ardisson de sa
carrière me fascine et j'aimerais trop
tu me racontes pendant les heures de
passage lui faire plusieurs partir en
vacances et d'avoir quelques côtés sur
le matelas qui lui pose des questions
sur sa carrière seulement sur sa
carrière mais le personnage mentez
[Musique]